love being a family right now I am
obsessed with something new that I may
not ever recover from run with it he's
done with it going I have moved on from
kdramas and I have graduated back into
the real world of blemishes and pimples
and real raw gritty sex and I I finished
a book a while ago by sally rooney who's
an Irish author and it's called normal
people and I was like Oh have they ever
do an adaptation of this it's never
gonna translate because it's a very like
sexually driven yet somehow deeply
emotional thing I was like it'll never
happen but it happened and it happened
quite possibly better than the book and
I am so just like I'll walk into the
room and she'll be tears in her eyes
because I can't believe it I go what
happened these people you can see their
digs and their pimples on their face I
have a pimple on my dick right now her
like sell point so it's so real with a
pimple on my dick
that's as real as it's been I don't want
dingleberry real Oh pimple real like
acne and stuff like that but I think
that I was watching too many like Korean
dramas where they would just kind of
like in post they would just smooth out
everyone's skin so no one really had any
features anymore and then they would
kiss like this babe let's do a Korean
drama kiss no no they would just put oh
oh no sound oh they would [ __ ] that's
how they would their makeout scenes
where there wasn't movement of the lips
so I think I was watching too much of
that so when I went to normal people and
it's just full bush really just real
looking people
I lost my mind it was almost like a
overdrive over stimulation of my senses
and I started crying and it was a yeah I
wish I could get like that way with the
show it's like I wish you know I can see
a show about a relationship and then
want to see it again
but for some reason if that's just those
are things that I just don't want
see I don't give a [ __ ] but even if you
like I was I really like the book it's
borderline like young adult I don't know
if you guys are into like why a stuff
but I think it's borderline that but it
is very simple I like simple easy reads
I don't need it to be in like Obama's
list of you know top books like
sometimes I read some of those that I'm
like wait a second like this is way
beyond my paygrade sure I really liked
Battlestar Galactica
I loved Battlestar collection like that
you know I mean there's gotta be some
cyborgs in it or something for me to
like oh I want to watch that again I
want to try Wes role you know I try I
try to I try to get into it when it
first came out and I was a little but I
I think I'm gonna try to get in that is
that good have you seen that I just
watched yesterday
watch the whole first season all three
season I saw the first season but then I
didn't want to see if the second season
but is it worth it I think it's worth it
third season yeah the second season is
not good little slow oh really yeah what
have you been watching Gilbert that you
could recommend to Papa the west-world
i season the one that just asked that
was really good his dad's good I haven't
seen that one
there's run I know runs a good one
everyone's done [ __ ] wrong wrong is it
sci-fi no like a love comedy okay
Bobby doesn't isn't in today I know you
don't want to talk about this baby but I
want to talk about it real quick